this video is sponsored by blink
it is some time in the distant future
your consciousness has been digitally
linked and integrated into a brain
machine interface located inside an orb
like spacecraft that was launched from
the dying planet of your origins like
all things your planet reached its final
moments as it's lonely star began to run
out of fuel ceasing all thermonuclear
reactions and growing into a red giant
on the way to its final ember slowly
engulfing your planet in the process in
an act of desperation you and many
others launched yourself into deep space
in an unlikely search for another planet
that can sustain life on its own like a
school of minnows you swim through the
sea of space each and individual
spacecrafts all coordinated together as
well as you can inside your spacecraft
your body is held in a cryogenic stasis
tube it will last indefinitely
throughout the journey your spacecraft
however will not sustained by a
circulatory process of Dark Matter
collection your fuel source is
essentially endless but your spacecraft
will face its inevitable demise through
erosion and/or malfunction it cannot
sustain the chaos that is the universe
nor the entropy that inhabits everything
inside it forever if you do not find a
planet in time that is at a minimum
tolerable to life you will never be able
to exist as a body with a home and the
timeline of your life will end with the
spacecraft's even with no guarantee of a
future even with being presented with
such a horrible circumstance at this
moment one could argue that you are
unfathomably lucky there were billions
of others left behind who died with the
planet all four horrible reasons that no
one deserved any more or less than you
deserve to be one of the ones that was
launched and beyond that amongst the
billions that were you are of the small
percentage who made it past the initial
launch hundreds of millions of others
combusted in the process of the launch
or met their demise early on in the
journey thereafter as a result of
collisions with space debris or
spacecraft malfunctions or by falling
off course and whatever else by the luck
of luck itself in
the odds of you making it even this far
or something around 1 and 400 trillion
and now you continue onward into the
unknown your spacecraft hurtles through
the galaxy equipped with a plethora of
technologies that assist you in the
mission of locating a new planet that
needs only one thing just the right mix
of everything in between intermittent
periods of extended sleep and autopilot
modes using your thoughts alone you
monitor your journey through the
spacecraft's navigation system you and
it do your best looking for Galactic
habitable zones in the entire galaxy at
best only about 10% make up what could
be considered these zones and the areas
within these zones that contain stars
suitable for livable planetary
conditions could be closer to less than
just 1% of the entire galaxy at the most
optimistic of estimations odds are less
than one in a million of finding a
planet that is tolerable to life let
alone cordial and that's not even
accounting for any of the other factors
that might happen to you along the way
for this whole thing to be successful in
total from start to finish your odds
would likely end up being somewhere
between one and four hundred quadrillion
and impossible to even have any odds at
all at this point
is a miracle of odds itself as you
continue to pass cold dry barren planets
all uninhabitable to you you lose more
and more hope without giving up entirely
you return to a long group coordinated
Auto piloted slumber
[Music]
after some unimaginable length of time
suddenly the interface awakes you it has
for the first time since being launched
detected a planet that seems to show
signs of potential and habitability you
and the lonely remaining survivors move
forth towards the planet in elated aw
over this impossible discovery as you
approach the interface retrieves imagery
and data revealing a planet that seems
to have just the right mass for just the
right force of gravity to keep you on it
while allowing you to still move just
the right mix of atmospheric conditions
for just the right mix of molecules to
form and sustain themselves as water and
oxygen just the right mix of warm and
cold temperatures never being too much
of either just the right proximity to
the nearest star for light and energy to
fuel just the right rhythmic order of
continued motion all just right to allow
nutrients to grow from the planet's
surface and for life to live as you
approach even closer the interface is
able to scan and interpret more imagery
and data revealing what looked to be
species of beings that look just like
you
mostly as if they are fundamentally no
different from you at all in this moment
you realize that not only are you going
to be able to live a life in your body
but against almost all conceivable odds
you happen to cross what seems like a
planet that is almost perfect for it a
planet with sunsets and ponds and oceans
and trees and food and life all shared
with others just like you the luck is
beyond absurd beyond the mere concept of
absurd and yet here you are
you continue closer and closer overjoyed
and anticipating your land before you
get too close though you probe the
entire planet one more time and all of a
sudden the interface reveals footage of
a previously unseen horror that awaits
you it shows you a misery that exists on
the planet that you will almost
certainly have to assume it shows you
disease and bacteria and germs that
cover the planet mostly all of which you
will be at risk of becoming infected by
it shows you that in many of those
beings that look just like you that you
will inexorably be a part
of exists the malevolence agreed of
violence a potential hatred it shows you
the horrible storms and tragedies and
disasters that the planet experiences
with no real warning and nothing much to
do about it the planet is at least
equally terrifying and horrible as it is
perfect and beautiful but by the same
token it is equally perfect and
beautiful as it is terrifying and
horrible in this moment you are
confronted with a choice
to land or not to land you consider how
with as far as certainty can be certain
this is your only hope at life and
against all possible odds you are here
at this distant solitary planet amidst
the cold dark of a seemingly unending
lifeless universe and with every
incoming ship including your own there
is the potential to bring to the planet
a compassion and love and the same
unbelievably favorable odds of hope that
got you here in the first place you make
what you believe is the obvious choice
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blankest
blink astiz a book summary service that
provides comprehensive overviews of
thousands of nonfiction books making it
easier to take in key information ideas
and frameworks in an efficient amount of
time covering a wide variety of topics
in areas like psychology health
philosophy science and much more Glinka
Staz a diverse inventory for just about
anyone if you're interested in topics
related to human nature and social
understanding and communication plinkus
tagged rate collection including several
titles by the author of Malcolm Gladwell
like blink talking to strangers in the
tipping point perhaps what's most
helpful is that by condensing complete
books down to around 15 minute summaries
plinkus can help you discover whether or
not a book is what you are looking for
without necessarily having to read the
full version first with self-education
being so important plinkus can be a very
useful tool in such an effort the first
100 people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access as well as 25% off a
full membership the free 7-day trial can
be cancelled at any time within the
trial period again if you're interested
please visit blankest comm slash pursuit
of wonder or click the link in the
description of course thank you so much
for watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]